six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our caller from the six two
three area code caller from six to three
go ahead I do my name is Nancy from
Arizona what's on your mind today I have
two parts actually yesterday I was
watching on YouTube and there was some
weird smudge on here forehead oh no I
don't know if you noticed it but I
certainly did this on every video I have
a screenshot of it it's like a weird
black line and a smudge directly only
yeah so listen what happened yesterday
is there was a brief moment where
because of my vigorous gesticulation a
piece of hair came down from the
position it's normally in and kind of
covered and I'm kind of replicating it
for the television audience it kind of
covered a bit of my forehead and it
created a very unflattering shadow and
then during the break I fixed it so
don't worry I'm fine okay it was I tried
to look separately but yeah no I believe
me you can delete this means I'm fine
I'll get my actual question you know I
watch you all the time and I hear you
say from time to time that like you
don't believe in certain things because
you haven't seen any proof that it
exists you know whatever subject I
handed it might be it doesn't exist or
it doesn't work I'm wanting you being a
person of you know intellect and
involved in education and an educated
person okay uh how far out of your way
do you go to disprove your belief how
okay so you said sometimes if someone
asked me if I believed something I say I
don't because I've not seen proof of
that and then your how will I go to
disprove my beliefs I mean I guess it
depends on the belief right so like I'm
not going to go too far investigating
whether we're really as Homo sapiens of
species that needs oxygen right like I'm
not gonna investigate that one too too
much but something else I might
investigate more I guess um like I don't
want to say this in like being ridiculed
by all conversation in YouTube but uh
like I'm a person that there's a
chiropractor you know I go there all the
time and I've seen a really really great
result
you know you don't believe in it we'll
just fine I have friends that don't
believe in it as well but like you know
I'm just wondering like they you know
that could be a subject but I'm
wondering like do you go as far as I
don't know talking to actual somebody I
seen the interviews with like an
exorcist but I don't yeah so if the
question is have I interviewed
chiropractors I have not but
chiropractic arts sciences I don't know
what to call it chiropractic is
something I over the last 10 years have
actually researched quite a bit I've
looked at to the extent that we have
peer-reviewed science on it I've looked
at that so like just since you picked
chiropractic that is actually one that
was of genuine interest to me and I have
a lot of people in my family that are
part of the medical community and so
that when that one was of interest to me
pretty early on and I've researched both
sides of that one quite a bit okay okay
all right very very good appreciate
appreciate the question